what is happening there reject nation
i got my buddy aaron alexandra with me
for a while now we've been seeing
comments of people man language aaron
alexander coming back on the channel for
those who watch our umbrella academy
season two reactions and we've been
looking for another show to do together
but
when it's the right time aaron it's the
right time and i think we found it
with invincible an amazon series i know
nothing about this i haven't even seen
this trailer for this movie
really uh show i know jk simmons is a
voice actor and i know
uh steven yun you you win
yeah walking dead i'm asian if i if i
mispronounced it
it like i mispronounced mispronounced
this is a good intro i'm a quality
professional youtuber
hey here guys thanks for being here
listen if you end up enjoying this
reaction make sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction
is up on youtube full-length watch along
where you sync up with the time code
will be available over at our patreon
page we're over there
we cover a whole bunch of television
we're at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights like how
you see here on youtube
or watch along both included at the same
tier you might have to do
some slight footage manipulation to make
sure this can just get visible on
youtube
even if that means it gets copyright
claimed but bottom line just trying to
get it delivered to you guys
gotta thank pritham jindal for editing
this video for us thank you buddy been
doing a great job aaron you excited hop
into this
hell yes super very good
i feel i feel invincible it's been a
while since you've been here
it's been a minute
[Music]
there we go you ready for next week
what's next week superhuman evasion
training
i'm supposed to learn to tuck and roll
away from a guy who can shoot lasers
from his eyes or
it's the job duh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] wait
you're not even gonna be here are you
sucks to be you i'll be living it up in
london seeing sights
eating indian food enjoy getting laser
burn
what what the hell
are these guys the main characters
yeah there's no superheroes in this
interesting approach
okay
should have taken training more serious
[Laughter]
oh damn
[Music]
i
oh [ __ ] did it work
oh god i
[Laughter]
what is happening
yo yo
oh is that guy like
oh [ __ ] get this guy out of here
what the hell
oh dear
is this the justice league
war woman
[Laughter]
this isn't a spectator
it's like batman and static shock yeah
sorry i wouldn't normally move so fast
but there were so many of you that
starts with one of you oh no oh god oh
no
[Laughter]
that would totally happen you're a fish
man
some kind of aqua man
oh damn no no no don't do that
oh god it's launched
just a launcher that killed her right
never by the head
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
[Laughter]
he looks like jay jonah james
nice nice
nice
the the action kind of moves like a dc
animated movie
yeah right yeah
that was cool what oh
man what is this show this is like a
regular superhero show
what i'll be out in a minute our main
character
interracial couple
[Laughter]
oh yeah
now let's get you out of that costume
boundaries
people you guys are going to best worst
i love that place that's clever when
your powers kick in you can go on your
own
salt on the wound dad they've got to be
due any day now son
this is like sky high have you seen sky
high it's kind of like that
not a long time waiting for his powers
to kick in be like a super dad
oh i can't believe the guardians of the
globe let them get that close to killing
the president
they didn't even get into the building
an omni man was there too
you're such an omni maniac way to root
for the underdog and that mustache
sorry okay straight stuff
that's what it is it's the gay thing
that makes me uncomfortable
nothing to do with my dad burger mart
that sounds gross this burger's ready to
go
walking with your cart dude yes walk in
and grab a burger and leave
yeah you get that trash
that was unexpected damn oh i feel bad
whoever that's gonna hit
sorry i'm late honest to god a dragon
was attacking hong kong
i stopped it ooh dragon nice mark was
getting ready to tell us how interesting
his day was
guess who's finally getting his powers
are you sure uh-huh pretty sure through
a trash bag
into space at work he must be stuck oh
that's great that's an odd response not
even blinking that's great
billions of miles from here out in deep
space
is the planet viltrum viltromites
are very similar to humans except we can
fly
move at super speed and possess great
strength
i volunteered to relocate to earth okay
so it's like
krypton and lantern court
yeah okay it feels like it looks mixed
together you're getting older
you're gonna get acne superpowers of
your own
i'm gonna be able to fly you accepted
the information really fast
yeah it he adjusted it's like i'm gonna
be able to fly
go for it do it oh god
don't look down stop looking down
[Music]
oh no way we did it
[Music]
wow
oh man
[Music]
oh damn this was like a scene out of a
movie
did he just go to space yeah it looks
like it it's above earth's atmosphere
ow damn
son right back to bed
let me run inside before anyone notices
god that was a dumb move bro
it's kind of like how you walk and you
don't think about balancing anymore
but when you were a baby you did you're
a baby flyer right now you have to focus
on staying upright
yeah i think i got it he's got crazy
eyes
a little bit what's his name uh
omnipresent omnibus
omni yeah try to hit me
use your whole body you can punch with
your arm
it'll take a while to get the hang of it
wow
he has to learn how to throw an actual
punch yeah freely move ourselves through
physical space
that's how we fly mr miyagi daddy on our
feet and push off the ground
wow we can literally push off anything
we can create our own leverage
wow
that is so cool such a sense of wonder
to this yeah
try it a little more like this like what
oh [ __ ]
jesus dad i didn't mean to hit you so
hard
i'm sorry ah are you sure
no one is going to pull their punches
what a terrible first day though
i really like the way he explained
flying though i know until he became
physically abusive
yeah all right even for super power
people how badly did that go
i pushed him pretty far did you maybe
push too far
are you questioning me oh what the hell
has gotten into you
i don't know i i can't help but think
maybe our lives would be better if he
hadn't gotten them at all
what is happening wasn't
he's it well he did get the impression
he he wasn't excited about his kid
having powers
there's still a dick that's a shitty
thing to say
peter don't abuse your powers against
anywhere near flash shops
please just don't don't
don't what don't kick your ass again
punch him in the chest
try it you know replay it what happened
last time nothing like compared to my
dad
hit me go on hit me as hard as you can
harder
damn nice i drink my piss
baby i'm gonna piss in my pants you're
gonna
squeeze it out wow a new costume
frodo suit training suit it's always
goggles
i could see somebody cosplaying this
this is so fascinating because this this
feels like a pg-13
show but i can't tell if it's r-rated
superhero right
but it's also got this r-rated edge too
it feels like it's walking a weird line
damn nice man
omni kid way to go whoa whoa whoa
you can't do that to him you look
ridiculous that's a great let's get out
of here
let's go to burger son so he he doesn't
even like wear
glasses or something when he's just
himself i don't think anyone knows who
he is
i don't know if he has a secret identity
may not look like much but you did
far more damage down there than you
needed to hit me
what hit me now do it i'm not gonna hit
you you never hit me before okay
it scared me it wasn't too much i could
take the pain i'm strong
i know you are i want to be just like
you
you will be son
follow me starting burgers
have you heard of a brothel there's one
in france we can go to right now
i am ah
this person makes super costumes
hello edna mose what do you think
well i don't know about the orange and
yellow looks exactly like the one behind
it
not your best work art can't blame a guy
for trying to move
unsold merch that's true
how often do they have just wasted ones
but i'm gonna need a little help from
you
have you decided on the name yet i
haven't really thought about it
think about it and get back to me i just
keep feeling like there's something like
much worse just
percolating around the corner yeah like
this can't just be a father-son show
right
there's nothing more happening that i've
i could just feel something coming
yeah it feels like something sinister
you seem tired people keep noticing we
keep training outside of our home
[Laughter]
they're starting to use their
smartphones too
our neighbors marching what if i can't
do this
you hear it i do oh damn
but you caught it i did that being a
superhero is no different that glove
would be better this is the beginning of
a long journey for you and me
it's okay to be scared you'll do just
fine kids your age think they're
invincible and it holds them back
careless the thing is you're different
you
actually are invincible that's the name
of the show
yeah got it
okay kid let's get to work oh that's his
name
oh i like that that's neato
[Music]
i guess that looks invincible yeah
part of me likes this other suit more
but i guess sure yeah yeah i kind of
like the other suit more i like the
black i'm a sucker for black
yeah you guys probably can't hear this
song on youtube
just letting you know it's cagey
elephant
oh that was cool wow
really great animation in this yeah oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well property damage yeah so it's about
yeah thinking i paid you a man of steel
all right
damn
whoa
i feel like he's having fun with that a
little too much fun well too much fun
it's like a soccer ball
that's emergency
okay because it's called superhero [ __ ]
i'm so bored
this [ __ ] doesn't happen down here
this is the longest mid-credit scene
i've ever seen
oh man take me with you come on i can
help
no nikki you know guardian's business
what is going on
what the [ __ ] is this alien hanging out
a little kid i thought the episode ended
i'll check back with you tomorrow
finally get a black batman
mm-hmm i respect it i'm not just excited
about it because you're right next to me
no no of course
i'd be just as excited if you weren't
here
i wouldn't be though none of us signaled
the alert
oh god what's going on that's our trap
[Music]
oh [ __ ] what
i told you had crazy eyes what the [ __ ]
damn red rush is saving the day
[Music]
really
oh [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
oh my god what the hell what
happened oh jesus
oh sh why is he murdering all them what
is
why oh
oh my god oh monster
what the [ __ ]
oh god
i can't believe what's happening right
now what is that
yeah yeah [ __ ] him up oh no
oh no oh
destroyed he's a murderer
you her
oh my god guys just run away
he's going oh god
oh my oh god no yeah
why what is happening why are you doing
this
oh my god what the [ __ ]
he just karate chopped his head off
[ __ ] broken jesus
okay okay
like i i had a feeling
that something bad was like there's
gotta be something there's gotta be some
hook here right because
right now i'm like it's just a stronger
language
typical superhero show
look at that like whoa what is up with
the longest
mid-credits scene in the world here oh
no
this is an important ass scene
that's just so funny because i i had
that feeling
when i was watching it of like this
is like that's a fun show it's a cool
show it's a good characterization show
and then
it ended but it said invincible i'm like
okay i guess it's just like a really
well put together superhero
show yeah and then bam look at the
unexpected i knew we had crazy eyes
yeah yeah you wouldn't
yeah i felt it i felt like i was i was
worried for the mom at first i'm like oh
god yeah
something's something being too nice and
i was like this this
this relationship between the father and
son is too sincere something has to drop
something's gonna
happen i was not expecting that they
gave me
they give all of them origins
all right let's talk about it let's talk
about this
all right so
i don't know
i'm shook i'm sure i'm i'm destroyed i
mean uh okay so this is robert kirkman
the guy who did walking dead yeah
because at first like when it started
off with the
with the with the security guards yeah i
was like what's
this what's ghosts right shows i was
like yeah i was like these this is the
main characters
okay i'm not sure what we're watching
there was something about the opening
scene of it that was
starting to give me some impressions i'm
like is this kind of like the boys but i
didn't know if
i was associating the boys only because
it's amazon i was on the lookout for
like an edgy superhero show like a show
that's like a superhero show but not
really a superhero show
is kind of the the thing i was expecting
for some reason even though i knew
nothing about the series
when we were watching it i was enjoying
it but i'll be honest there was a part
of me
that by the time it said invincible of
going
i'm not sure why this is like super
special right now
right why is it so popular yeah it took
me a little bit of time to
i was like okay maybe it just takes a
few episodes you know maybe like okay by
the time
they released the first three i heard so
maybe i gotta get like the same way how
boy season two
was you gotta watch the first three
episodes to get into it right i was like
okay maybe i gotta watch the first three
to really get into it and see what makes
this unique cause
right now i was like it's a really well
executed play on tropes that i've seen
just with a little bit more mature
language
is kind of the overall impression i was
getting like it felt familiar
it felt extremely familiar what was it
bringing to the table
that other shows did not bring yeah or
you didn't really you didn't really get
that
at first no for most of it it was like
okay there's like some medic comment
i kept we kept referencing other things
from like the justice league and to like
even going to sky
high like oh these are all this feels
like a mature
family superhero show but i keep
thinking there's something worse
happening
yeah you get this like this kind of
seedy thing like there's something
darker
gonna happen just because you know like
robert kirkman and just like this seems
a little like
too good to be true yeah something feels
off and then
lo and behold get traumatized by the end
like it's like oh that that's what
okay that's why we're here that's what i
mean like i got i was very much
appreciative of the animation the flying
was really cool
the flying was great i love the
attention to detail there like they do a
great job on selling you on
no this is a superhero show like i was
thinking of
like dc animated movies specifically
especially with the way the fight scenes
were going down
that's what was also selling me was the
were they they called the guardians
yes they say the guardians uh the way
with the guardians that was another
thing that was really selling me they
don't seem like they're
parodying them they seem like they're
doing just their own versions of them
right yeah
yeah at the beginning was amazing yeah
so cool
the end credit scenes when they're
cutting to all them like yeah there's
some
there's some commentary like aquaman
being an actual fish and he's bored in
atlanta's you know yeah it was like
going down i just want to go back out to
the surface
there's like some commentary but it
wasn't to the point of how
when you watch the boys of oh it's
clearly making fun of that you know
right there was parts where i was like
are we doing a medic commentary or are
we homaging like what what's happening
here yeah
is it spoof or not and so there were
times where i was kind of totally
confused that it weirdly all clicks by
the time you get to that final moment
oh you're like oh oh
something crazier is going on here damn
that was
nuts yeah yeah i'm happy you like i know
a lot of people really love this comic
book and luckily i
know nothing about like the source
material so i just like went into this
blind it does a great job of walking the
line between
like the stuff we know from the boys
with it being like kind of more uh
more of a commentary but also being
genuine like the the thing with like the
where the flash rip-off was uh trained
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah train
adrian uh yeah when he was when he was
going back and forth and they started
puking
yeah he's going so fast yeah so i mean
it's subtle it was not subtle but it was
minimal it wasn't like
let's really poke a stick into the
justice league here it looked like they
were honoring them to a certain extent
like some of the family angle too oh
that's actually some of my favorite
parts of you know he's a superhero dad
and then he comes home and the wife is
just so used to him
like this is just what he does that
there's no wonder to what he does
right it's very it's very normalized
like the lines you said about the dad
being late for dinner or whatever
because like
he was fighting a dragon or something
yeah yeah he's like yes
that's interesting your son was telling
us about it you know like
take more interest in your son i will
say the one thing i did really
appreciate about this show
about this first episode was the fact
that there's no denying
the fact that omni man looks like jay
jonah jameson
yeah yeah i'm sure
that's like that's how it looks in the
comics as well the fact that they made
the deliberate choice for him not to do
that
j jones jameson voice even though he
very much looks like that character and
i'm sure
in some degrees based off of him at
least visually uh he sounds more like
i know you said you probably you haven't
seen this show but uh legend of korra jk
simmons voice is a character named
tenzin
mentory heart felt kind of performance
you get those two different sides of jk
and i'm glad they chose that route
because i feel like them making him like
a heartfelt dad
makes the the punch of what we just saw
at the end with him being so brutal
makes it so
so jarring yeah yeah that's such a great
call that's a great point glad you're
here
that's a great point yeah there are
those two sides of jk jk simmons's voice
you have like the jay jones jamison the
whiplash
version of like really loud bombastic in
your face
yeah yeah yeah and then you do have a
little bit more of this subtler side to
jk simmons
actually applying that to his voice was
part of what was making me a little more
suspicious but in the right ways because
there were times where i was really won
over by the charm and the mentorship
side of him
okay i guess he is just an extremely
cautionary
alien posing as a human you know like
all right i think that's
what it must be even he gets like a
little bit of a moment where he snaps at
his wife like are you questioning me
then he calms down it's like i don't
know
like he's apologizing in order to have
that impact of the explosive violence
you need to have the opposite which is
the calm collected in
itself in controlled self but i'm like
okay is this why he's so worried about
his son getting superpowers yeah i
wonder
if what he's saying like what he tells
his son is like the truth
like not the whole truth you know yeah
yeah yeah he made a big deal about the
fact that his son was getting powers
like he seemed like
sort of freaked out by that so like what
what are the implications of that like
what does that mean down the road
maybe maybe there's one little theorem
there because i'll watch the second
episode right away
but one little theory i'll lay out is
the world that he comes from i'm not
remembering the name of right now but
the kryptonian
lantern like world ville viltrum
it starts with a v i know that much
[Laughter]
vulcan vulcan they seem like the
the aesthetic and the civilization
appeal look of it was like
like krypton except for the fact that
like they already have superpowers but
the fact that they have superpowers and
then when they come of age and they go
out and help
people uh and then like he he assigned
himself to earth it's like oh that's
kind of like the lanterns i wonder if
helping means cleansing like conquering
like maybe it's like a like a zod kind
of thing
yeah yeah that's what i mean yeah wow oh
interesting because
you got this they really hook you into
this mark is the sun right
yeah yeah so they really hook you into
the sun
his journey i love the voiceover that's
stephen young he's doing the performance
oh it's cool robert kirkman all right
his performance and then he is kind of
like the peter parker
uh version here uh of being in school
and
but i like how he's got this bit of an
angry edge to him yeah
yeah he's frustrated which complements
really well
with when you see what his father does
at the end yeah because he had him
have that sort of anger inside of him
exactly like that's
really fascinating writing hmm
[Music]
oh i like that oh there's a lot of
places where this can go
but then to have the father-son element
of that like because this was a
father-son show story about adolescence
and
and a coming-of-age tale and now it's
got this like crazy superhero
super villain
yeah i got weird vibes from the dad
because like they're not blinking thing
but like never did i think it was going
to go that far
that direction it's fascinating what
they can do because with animation you
got to be a lot more specific
when you're doing the subtlety of body
language and facial expressions to
communicate but live performance you
gotta
you just rely on the actor to be subtle
and then audiences can pick up on
whatever
whatever they want by interpreting the
performance for me the crazy ice things
was really
coming in at the dinner table of when
he's talking with his son he's like you
sure he got powers like the way the way
how he's behaving
was it didn't seem villainous but there
was something that just seemed off about
him
yeah yeah you know and i'm like okay
he's a full-on villain it doesn't
make sense at least from what we know so
far like why would he do something like
that
why protect people but also destroy the
heroes that are just doing it out of
their own
volition and stuff but i really loved
the way that violence was executed yeah
like a lot of the
fight scenes were like the dc animated
movies kind of like a certain anime
where
whenever they move the camera slightly
follows
with them you know that's what i was
thinking of when watching this
and then when you get to those really
violent parts i love that because
okay he wiped out one whoa what the hell
he did it so violently every time you
think they might have a drop on him they
don't
like he you see that he's not that you
can you can put up a
fight but you won't win it could have
just been like a homelander situation
where you just like
instantly wiping them out where here
there were moments where he was caught
and he was being hit
he was being taken down but then bam he
would always figure out a way to
out strength or outsmart during the
fight that was wow
it's weird that you could happily leave
this with an impression of
that's cool you know i'm not sure
exactly what the hue type is but it's
cool
too oh i see it now just in this
one once expanded out scene and i think
it's great that they decided to hook you
into the wonder
and the nostalgia of the superman
superboy relationship
and then go but it's not that big
no yeah i think it's wild the fact that
how you were talking about
the the post-credits scene like it adds
a whole new layer of context
yeah to this whole thing because i feel
like the episode itself was very
not deprived but like it was very light
on like the the gore and the action that
we eventually do see
because they were focusing on like the
like yeah this is this is your
your typical like family show your young
justice your spider-man
spectacular spider-man and then oh no
this is amazon
yeah yeah yeah we don't do that here
i'm actually really respect that they
let you
they could have easily teased something
much
darker earlier on so that way they could
prepare you for that but it hits you
with a much bigger shot that's great
yeah all right i gotta watch the next
episode guys what'd you think subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button keep a look out for our next
reaction these will be spread out take
time to put together
just to get public on youtube all right
get it public everyone don't don't
comprehend that
appreciate this man only other reactors
know what i'm talking about that's
just the goal to get it public hit that
like button last but not least
anissa oliva anisa we got a whole
bunch of gifts john and i did an
unboxing video for patreon they filmed
today we got a whole bunch of gifts from
her
that video you wanna like this is just
to give you an idea
yes john and i make commentary about the
gifts sure but normally an unboxing
video is like
10 minutes this video turned into 55
minutes
there's a lot of great stuff in there
this is not even scratching the surface
this is a shirt oh this shirt she gave
and then i'll show
one awesome thing that [ __ ] like there's
a like a whole bunch of stuff but
there's one more awesome thing
oh wow aaron hasn't even seen this i
don't know what i'm about to see
see that it's real rejects and then it's
all superhero
gold that's so cool she drew this
you're amazing this is one out of like
30 gifts
so anissa you rock i love you
um yeah this is this is absolutely
incredible anisa you are incredible
thank you that's so dope now i'm sorry
for the pictures i sent you
after i didn't know what to send
and we don't need to get lawyers
involved
this isn't this isn't going to be
no no lawyers no lawyers i don't know
what i was going to say but you know
what
you got to learn to yeah it's your first
time back in a year you're right
[Music]